Have you read the science behind blood type diets? Do you have any thoughts on whether this is legitimate or wacky?
So I remember when that blood type diet book came out. There was back in the 80s. I think good to say it was a long time ago. I read that book.
There's a lot of it that was very interesting. I can see how it's extremely
appealing to a lot of people because then I can just
see if I have a type A type B type O blood type and then I can see what I should eat and some people
I've had I had patients over the years. I said that really fit me perfectly. I have a type A blood type
and that means that I really shouldn't eat meat and I've been out of vegetarian diet and I feel really great doing it.
Do I think it's legitimate? Honestly, no, I don't think it's legitimate at all.
Partly the reason why I disagree with it is that he's basing all of his scientific evidence on blood type diets
based upon what he believes of the evolutionary tree, which I am not a fan of. I don't think it's correct
and I don't think there's a lot of legitimacy about it at all. In fact, it's kind of
been proven to be a little hokey because I can't tell you how many people that it didn't fit.
It was the exact opposite of I do think that there's people that do better on eating less meat.
And I think there's people that do better eating a lot more meat. But I don't think it has to do
with blood type. I think it has to do with genetics. So if person has a lot of
bad gene defects, then I'd say they probably don't do as well eating a high meat diet. They wouldn't
do well on a carnivore type diet. But if a person has a lot of HIF1A defects, that's a gene.
At the end point, they're going to calluses. They wouldn't do well on a vegetarian
high carbohydrate diet. So I think it has more to do with genetics than it has to do with
I don't think it has anything to do with blood type. So that's why I opinion.